so Moon Knight and Venom are teaming up
in this video and as a bonus we're going
to answer the question where's blade in
the middle of all of this because after
the last video you guys have been dying
to know so what this does here before we
get to Venom and really even blade this
basically picks up with what is an
effect a series of hits that are taking
place in New York against what's called
The Shadow cabinet now the shadow
cabinet is basically a group of people
who serve as Mark spector's informants
and that's one of the things to
understand yes Mark spector's Moon
Knight is incredibly capable but he's
only as capable as the people who feed
him information specifically the Jake
lockley Persona right like the
personality of Moon Knight that's the
cab driver that just kind of keeps his
ear to the ground on what's going on now
where him and Rhys and other members of
the Moon Knight team are trying to like
track down these various people and
basically save them before they can be
destroyed one of the things that I do
want to specify here and a question that
I want to answer is what's going on with
like the moon God conch one of the
things to remember is that coming out of
the story where Moon Knight fought and
basically overpowered The Avengers that
at the end of that Khan true was
imprisoned so he's basically locked away
in and Asgardian prison the problem with
this is that because he's locked away if
Mark Spector dies again he cannot be
resurrected he'll stay Dead Forever so
he has to be very careful with his life
and that's why you don't necessarily see
him being as rambunctious as he normally
is because if he were to jump into a
building like in the instance of Sigmund
one of his informants who's blown up if
he gets caught in that and he dies it's
curtains there's no coming back so it's
one of those cool things right now all
that will basically be fixed once konshu
is released from his prison which
inevitably he will be but the thing here
is that as they start to realize what's
going on what Rhys does is she says I
want to talk to the Jake lockley Persona
and that's when Jake comes forward right
that's when his personality manifests
and she literally tells him okay you
know all these people each one of these
informants are Part of Your Inner Circle
give me a trail give me something to
indicate what's going on you know all
the back roads in New York and once he
dies he starts to realize these Hitmen
are kind of making their way through a
kind of path they're starting all the
way in the South and working their way
up North through the entirety of New
York and so it really kind of gives them
an indication of like who's next so what
it does is it basically allows Moon
Knight and his forces to basically catch
these guys before they can make their
final attack and effectively he
overpowers them incredibly fast but
that's when he starts to realize
something bigger is going on here
because these are essentially the
Harlequin Hitmen they're not by any
standard of measurement important right
they are just run-of-the-mill people who
just kind of go and do these hits right
they're Z level villains and so once he
starts to realize they're the ones that
are going through and taking out members
of moon Knight's Shadow cabinet someone
else is controlling them someone else is
telling them what to do now that's when
he basically brings in Dr Sturman for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar Dr
Sturman is basically Mark spector's
therapist she says she's not part of the
Moon Knight crew she essentially is even
if she doesn't want to admit it but she
knows enough about Psychotherapy and how
the brain works to understand they've
been manipulated on a psychological
level it wasn't drugs or anything along
those lines someone's using sound to
screw with their heads and so what you
end up doing here is picking up for a
brief moment with the character of Blade
and the reason why that matters is
because remember Reese is part of the
Moon Knight team but she's also a
vampire and she's been turned relatively
recently and what that means is one she
can't fully control her vampire
abilities but the bloodlust and
everything is also a part of that
equation as well so Moon Knight calls in
a favor with blade and says I need you
to train Rhys and teach her how to
become an effective vampire we'll see
him like one more more time here in a
minute but then he doesn't really appear
again right maybe we'll end up getting a
moon night blade team up which makes the
most sense considering that like Moon
Knight's killing vampires right you'd
think blade would show up somewhere
along the line but what you end up doing
here is picking up with Rhys and Soldier
now Soldier is also a vampire but as we
saw in the previous videos he's a
vampire because of the fact that a
bullet was shot through Rhys which also
went through Soldier and the blood that
was on the bullet from Reese went into
Soldier and infected him with vampirism
is it a kind of hand wavy thing sure but
it's also kind of cool to be honest with
you guys and so what they do is they
basically go out and party right like
they're literally in the nightclub
partying and doing their thing it's kind
of cool right I mean it was like me and
a buddy of mine at the Ultra Music
Festival this year when I popped Molly
right like come on guys let's rave it
was pretty amazing but what she does is
she kind of like Muses for a second
right this is not particularly important
to the story but I think it is a cool
element right she kind of Muses for a
second about what it means to be a
vampire and like be in a nightclub right
she's like I could hear how every human
body there responded to the music right
heartbeats aligning to the bass shaking
their blood rattling their lungs
everybody there on the same wavelength
the same Rhythm like one Instinct
sharing a thousand bodies it's a pretty
cool way to kind of see this but getting
back into the main story itself
everything goes sideways when the DJ is
essentially removed from the stage and
like this new guy shows up who kind of
looks like Doctor Doom although a more
awesome version of Doctor Doom but it's
not Doctor Doom and literally like
replaces the playing record with a new
record and when he does it starts
emanating this kind of sound wave right
this pulse that actually just like sends
everybody in the nightclub into like
just this crazy rage-filled frenzy right
now it does not affect Rhys and it does
not affect Soldier anybody there who's
effectively a vampire all the normal
humans who were there are totally
overtaken by this and they all start
killing each other I mean like beating
each other to death all kinds of stuff
right it's just complete and total
Madness now Moon Knight just sort of
appears here because the story or at
least this portion is told from Reese's
perspective we can just largely assume
he got some kind of information that
told him what was going on but he
basically shows up here and then
alongside Rhys and Soldier just kind of
starts overpowering people but what ends
up happening is Reese reflects back for
a moment on her training with blade when
she turns into a kind of missed form and
one of the things that blade had
informed her is that as a vampire you
have all kinds of abilities at your
disposal one of the things you can do is
turn into a sort of dust form and
teleport effectively from one place to
another now the range in which a person
can do this is relative to their level
of power and really their age as a
vampire so someone like Dracula just
using an arbitrary standard here could
like teleport across the world whereas
Rhys can teleport like 10 feet that way
right so it's just one of those things
that's relative to their abilities but
what he tells her is that this kind of
disassociation with regards to like her
molecules turning into a dust form
disappearing reappearing that that's the
easy part the difficult part is bringing
herself back together and if she doesn't
learn how to master it effectively she
could turn herself into a kind of like a
dust form and then be blown away right
caught by the wind and just dispersed
among the atmosphere never to be able to
reconnect herself again and like that's
the last time we see blade
sorry to break your all's Hearts we do
not get a massive blade crossover here
it would be dope if we did and hopefully
we do in the future but for the most
part Moon Knight and Reese and Soldier
are able to like bring some measure of
order to the chaos and then ultimately
this guy just kind of takes off right he
basically escapes but what restarts to
realize is this guy going into a
nightclub playing this music and sending
everybody into a frenzy it was a proof
of concept right can this work can using
sound to drive people insane and control
people's minds can it work right because
presumably this is the guy who was
behind the Harlequin Hitman and so what
we end up doing here is jumping over to
the Venom segment of this video and what
ends up happening is you initially pick
up with like a handful of mercenaries
who were standing outside the Midnight
Mission and Dylan Brock himself is
sitting with Moon Knight and having a
conversation now Sidetrack from the
story for a second for everybody who's
not familiar with what's going onto the
Venom Comics we're not going to go
through everything something to
understand here is Eddie Brock is quote
unquote dead meaning his physical form
is gone his Essence is out there dealing
with the whole thing with like you know
Meridius and the different versions of
Venom that he'll be calm and so on and
so forth it's pretty cool the Venom
symbiote is currently bonded to his son
Dylan so Dylan Brock is like the Venom
that you see running around in Marvel
Comics right now but the reality here is
that since Dylan has become venom he's
constantly been chased down by alcamax
and the life Foundation to organizations
that are trying to find a way to attain
the Venom symbiote and then rework it
for their own ends right weapons
manufacturing or selling it off to the
highest bidder or using it for military
applications whatever it happens to be
and so what ends up happening here is
that in the conversation Dylan is very
Coy about who he is and what he's
capable of but he was told by Eddie
Brock at one point in time that he can
trust Moon Knight and because these
groups are constantly after him Moon
Knight is the man that he seeks out and
so that's when he reveals that he's
basically Venom now the cool thing is
that at that moment Moon Knight brings
him in and then he goes outside and then
he talks to The Mercenaries and in the
most Moon night way ever he tells them
like Dylan Brock is under my protection
which means you have two choices you can
go home and chalk this one up to
misadventure or you can come and try to
take him but I'll tell you this there's
nothing but pain and Terror awaiting you
inside my house and let me tell you guys
something man if a dude's standing
outside his house right standing at his
door and he tells me if you come inside
there's nothing but pain and Terror
awaiting you that's reason enough for me
to leave right that's reason enough for
me to be like all right bro uh I'll see
you when I see you right peace out nope
they're mercenaries and that's what he
tells Dylan Dylan's like is this going
to work and the response of Marcus of
course it's not gonna work they're
mercenaries right their job is to bring
you in otherwise they don't get paid and
then will do whatever it takes to make
that happen so understand they are going
to enter into this place and what he
does is he kind of gives him a
play-by-play of exactly how to make
things work right how to come out on top
with these guys and it's kind of a cool
thing because it gives us like a little
bit of insight into how Mark Spector
works now one of the things that he
could have done here is he could have
let like the Midnight Mission consume
them because remember the house that
Moon Knight operates in it's sentient
that's the reason why when they run
inside the house it doesn't look
anything like it traditionally should
it's almost kind of like Moon Knight's
version of Doctor Strange's sanctum
sanctorum right when you walk inside the
Midnight Mission and you're not supposed
to be there you pay your money and take
your chances because God only knows
what's going to happen to you but the
funny thing is like once they're inside
Moon Knight starts to taunt them and
that's when like in one of the most dope
panels that I think I've ever seen him
and Venom just like descend on these
guys now he tells Venom right off the
bat at the least dangerous person is
also the one that we have to be the most
concerned about a character named tangle
because tangle all she really has the
ability to do is like tangle us up right
and just kind of like put us in a
vulnerable state well that's not the
most important thing given the nature of
everybody else's power super strength
all that kind of stuff if we're tangled
up we immediately get taken out right
like it's one of the craziest things
sure she can't do a whole lot to us but
between their ability to shoot lasers
and humble us to death and so on and so
forth we need to remove her first
because once she's taken out of the
equation then all bets are off all we
have to do is find a way to overcome
their various Powers which won't be the
most difficult thing to do now as you
guys are probably asking yourself what
are the powers of these mercenaries even
in the first place like why is Moon
Knight worried about them okay so this
group is known as the new enforcers like
we mentioned Tangled has the ability to
like tingle people up she actually emits
tendrils from her fingernails eel can
use electricity Blitz has super strength
and enhanced agility and then thermite
can just fire like an overwhelming
amount of heat at people but as you guys
can probably tell these guys abilities
are designed to overcome a Venom Symbian
but by extension of that they're also
designed to overcome someone like Moon
Knight so that's kind of the concern
here and that's why they have to hit
them in a particular order now for the
most part they do right they take these
guys out quite readily but that's when
Dylan chimes in and responds to Moon
Knight and the reason why I say that is
because Moon Knight really tells them
like you should have been able to take
these guys out quite readily right like
one the Venom symbiote is not as weak as
it used to be you've become a lot more
powerful since like the old school days
when I used to fight and then also Ally
myself with Eddie Brock but the response
of Dylan is yes but there's like this
sound that's emanating through the city
and it's basically throwing us off
because remember symbiotes do have a
weakness to sound which means they have
heightened senses in relation to sound
and so when Moon Knight kind of puts two
and two together thinking about the
whole nightclub event with Rhys then he
says like take me to this person right
take me to the sound and that's when the
two of them start tracking down a guy by
the name of Sydney sarnak now again
what's interesting about this is Moon
Knight spilling this information to
Dylan Brock he basically tells him like
whatever it is that Sydney's working on
like it's something big using sound to
manipulate people that's no small thing
and he even tells Venom like if he's
using like Sonic devices to achieve this
goal then that's why you're even picking
this sound up in the first place and so
once they get to the headquarters of
Sydney of course they both roll in there
and despite the fact that there's armed
guards and so on and so forth they take
them out pretty fast right so like Venom
focuses on the guards and then Moon
Knight takes off after Sydney himself
the problem is that when he gets there
he ends up discovering what is in effect
a Panic Room and inside this room is
Sydney sarnak himself now the question
has to be asked here how did Mark even
know to go after Sydney sarnak in the
first place so something to understand
this guy is not a new villain when it
comes to the Moon Knight comics in fact
he's been around since the old werewolf
By Night comics and I'm pretty sure he
appeared back in issue number nine but
he was a former sound engineer who was
the best in the business and ultimately
ended up becoming a villain so that's
how Moon Knight knew to go after this
guy it's one of the things that I hope
you're noticing about the Moon Knight
comics with Jed McKay writing them is
very much a villain of the week type
story but because of how they're written
they're amazing and so once he gets to
this Panic Room with Sydney inside we
get the total opposite of what we
expected here which is not really him
saying like I knew you were coming Moon
Knight and now we're gonna fight to the
death and we're gonna see which one of
us is the greatest no he literally says
like you're not going to capture me and
the reason why is because the police
were called as soon as you cross the
perimeter I'm turning myself in for all
of my crimes I would rather do that than
let you take me now on the surface this
looks like Sydney is terrified of Mark
Spector that's not the case in fact this
is all part of the plan he's getting
himself in jail because he wants to be
in jail it's like that Punisher story
The Cell right like he gets himself in
jail because he wants to be in jail
because there's a much bigger plan going
on here that's exactly what it is now
Moon Knight of course being a vigilante
as soon as the cops show up they would
immediately come for him so he basically
tells Dylan like we have to get out of
here if we don't they're going to try to
arrest us and of course Alco Max and the
life foundation will certainly come for
you if you're behind bars or you'll
simply just be handed over to them but
what he does once they leave and they
get back to the Midnight Mission is he
tells Dylan there's a place for you here
if you want to join my team now one of
the things to know if there was no Venom
solo Series going on right now this
would absolutely be an instance where
like Dylan would join Moon Knight even
if only for a temporary amount of time
but because the story of Dylan is being
told in a separate comic book he chooses
not to right he's like okay no I'm not
going to join you I have my own thing
going on but he does give Moon Knight a
warning and he says you are very much
like my father right you were at one
point a villain you're trying to be a
good guy I don't know if I'd really call
Moon Knight a villain per se but he has
done some pretty crappy things over the
course of his time so I think he does
kind of fit the mold of being a villain
if we're being honest with ourselves but
he says I get that you're trying to
redeem yourself and you're trying to do
something better be careful that's what
got my father killed so it's really kind
of a cool warning for Mark Spector
himself but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace